I want you to understand this project I
want you to understand it
I'm driven by guilt guilt and gratitude
I'm driven by them because I'm so
thankful and I feel so honestly guilty
and I feel so grateful to my parents and
my circumstance I thank them I thank
everybody for all those losses I took
along the way from the kids that made me
drink piss out of a Pepsi can because I
couldn't speak English in Dover New
Jersey that probably subconsciously
created a scenario when I don't even
mention it in the narrative of my youth
that's right fun fact I lived in Dover
for a year and a half before I got to
Edison New Jersey the Queen's to Jersey
thing has Dover erased from its history
because of the pain and the punishment
that that neighborhood put on me as a
little [ __ ] that couldn't speak
English
I thank you Dover
all those losses I think not having the
speed or the height or the athleticism
to allow me to compete and the thing
that I love the most in my youth I thank
the school system for creating a game
that does not allow the ambitious and
creative and the people that see it to
succeed in the short term as they try to
create the output that they need for
their audacity and their blind belief I
thank the friends and family who
whispered behind my back who casted a
narrative of my success because I was
losing in the framework of the 80s and
90s where a college and school was the
only variable of an indicator of your
success I thank them and most of all I
thank my mother and father and my sister
and brother
who lived in the cocoon that I lived in
for the first 18 years of my life that
was limited by the friends and family
outside of us that was limited in its
vacation time escapism that was limited
in its abundance that would have become
the weapons of my shortcomings I think
and I have gratitude and guilt for that
eighteen-year framework that created the
[ __ ] monster than I am the emotional
[ __ ] powerhouse that I am I thank the
worlds were taking away three of my four
grandparents didn't allow me to get to
know them which created a game that
allowed me to not have loss in those
early years that pain I thank them all
and I'm extreme in my gratitude and
guilt as I create this project on this
plane on this day in this year on this
moment and I want my audience to
understand that I Spit [ __ ] flames
and bars for the rest of my life kind of
guilt and gratitude because I want it so
[ __ ] bad for you I feel
Europeans and shortcomings I feel them I
see them I read them I sense them I can
taste that and what I want from you what
I want for you is what I have
emotionally and I'm driven by gratitude
and guilt and I try to put you on
through these platforms
as a
as a head nod and a respect to my
parents and my status as an immigrant in
a country at a time that rewarded that
framework
so I come to you and deliver you the
project on the plane
as a collect grant
that I hope inspires
a switch from defense to offense
that becomes the fuel to your happiness
and I remind all of you all your
shortcomings and losses and negativity
is yesterday it is all fundamentally
behind you even the worst of it and it
is up to you to step forward and start
positive offense as your new truth and I
beg that for you and I hope this [ __ ]
project suffocated and inspired it and
created it and enabled it
and they loved